all right this will be quick last night
i was able to go to a screening of 15
minutes of guardians of the galaxy shown
in imax 3d and i just want to let you
guys know what i thought initial
impressions are really i got exactly
what i came for the thing feels fun
which is exactly what i want guardians
of the galaxy to be i want it to be just
a rip-roaring good time what we got was
one pretty much continuous scene set
with the main characters in a jail i
don't want to give too much more than
that just because i don't want to go
into spoilers not knowing how far into
the film this this thing actually is but
we see some interaction we get some
humor we get some action and all of it's
looking pretty good the action's fun and
energetic the characters are really
interesting i was surprised how front
and center rocket raccoon is he's he's
gonna steal this movie people are gonna
be coming out of the theater loving him
more than anybody else and actually at
least as far as this scene is concerned
he's
being built up a bit like the leader of
the group i don't know if it'll actually
pan out that way but it'd be an
interesting way to go if they do the
animation for the character bradley
cooper's voice all of it just comes
together it's spot on it's perfect he's
just this little ball of attitude it's
terrific as for the other characters
gamora works really well for me because
in the performance zoe saldana brings
this sense of she wishes she had a
higher quality of people to be hooking
up and teaming up with but she's gonna
work with what she's got chris pratt as
peter quill is bringing pretty much
exactly what we saw in the trailer this
sense of he's a bit of a smart ass and
he's also just completely out of his
depth the fun thing is he pretty much
knows that he's got some buttons that
get pushed a little bit in the scene but
for the most part he's just trying to
keep his head on his shoulders i was
surprised at how well groot works first
of all the fact that the only line he
ever says and will ever say in the
entire course of the movie is i am groot
you'd think well that's there's not
going to be much to this thing he's
going to be an automaton there's a
surprising amount of personality in this
creature both in the variations of the
delivery of that single line that we get
from vin diesel and the voice work but
also he's not the fastest thing going on
he but he does have a general sense of
what's going on and he tries to be
helpful and he gets angry you know
there's enough there that he can get
emotional in certain directions and it
that comes across really well and he's
also just a straight up badass you don't
want to mess with this tree which brings
us to david batista as drax now this is
the one that seems like it might be a
slight problem initially his performance
was throwing me off in terms of his line
delivery it's hard to explain exactly
what was off about his line delivery but
then it's explained by rocket raccoon
that he comes from a species that
doesn't get metaphor they take
everything literally and what he
actually says is metaphor just goes over
his head and drax then says nothing goes
over my head my reflexes are too fast i
would catch it and the minute he said
that i'm like okay now i get what this
guy's deal is and now i'm on board with
the performance even though it got me to
come around in terms of his performance
i'm still questioning his function
within the team though as i mentioned
groot is a badass and you know can
definitely throw down in a fight rocket
can too though he obviously he needs
weapons where his group is more of a
brawler gamora is definitely very hands
on hands more acrobatic so that's a nice
contrast to groot drax just seems like
another big force brute fighter and with
groot and zelda already in the mix
filling out that that role he seems he
seems redundant now hopefully in the
bigger scope of the picture he'll have
more of a function but in the scene that
we got you know he was there and he was
fine but he didn't feel like he was
bringing a lot to the proceedings that
wasn't already covered by the other
characters but that's the only thing
that i could say was any sort of point
of concern for me the humor was great
the performances were fun the special
effects are really good the action was a
lot of fun the action scene was really
well paced it doesn't really raise my
level of excitement for this movie i was
already pretty excited but it reaffirms
that that excitement as far as the imax
and the 3d goes they were fine i'm not
going to pay the extra money to see it
in imax 3d that's just how i got to see
this preview section but at the end of
the day it's the movie i care about and
the movie looks really fun it looks like
it could potentially be the most fun i
have at the theater this year that'd be
a stretch with some of the stuff i've
gotten to see but i will definitely be
checking out when it comes out in
theaters hope you will too and when it
does maybe we can even talk about it but
until then this council is adjourned